SPEAKER: How are you
coordinating and managing
your workflows?
If you're using cron
jobs with custom scripts,
you know that it can get super
tricky to stitch together
all of your services
and applications
together to build a workflow,
especially as your workflow
scales in size and complexity.
In this video, we'll explore
some of the orchestration
services that Google Cloud
has to support your workflows.
So what is orchestration?
Orchestration refers to the
automated configuration,
coordination, and management of
computer systems and services.
You can think of
orchestration as the process
of stitching all of your
services and applications
together to build an
end-to-end workflow.
Perhaps you want to automate the
execution of a single service
at a specific time of the day.
Or maybe you have a more
sophisticated approach
of not just
automating one service
but automating,
coordinating, and monitoring
multiple services over
longer periods of time.
There are several
orchestration tools
that Google Cloud has to
help support your workflows.
These include Cloud
Scheduler for scheduling
single repetitive
tasks, Workflows
for complex multi-service
orchestration,
and Cloud Composer for
data-driven workloads.
First, we have Cloud Scheduler.
Cloud Scheduler is a
simple scheduling tool
that allows you to
schedule the execution
of a single HTTP-based
service on a recurring
schedule you define.
Many customers use Scheduler
alongside other Google Cloud
tools like Pub/Sub
and Cloud Functions
to execute their code
in a serverless manner.
Cloud Scheduler is
great if you need
to call a single service
at regular intervals.
For example, you could
use Cloud Scheduler
to schedule the execution
of a Cloud Function
that sends out daily
emails with top news
stories about technology.
But what if you have
multiple services
that you need to chain together,
feeding the output of one
service to the next?
Or what if you need to apply
complex logic to determine how
and when services are invoked?
This brings us to Workflows.
Workflows is a service
for orchestrating
multiple HTTP-based services
into a durable and stateful
workflow.
Like Cloud Scheduler,
Workflows allows
you to automate the execution
of HTTP-based services running
on Cloud Functions and Cloud
Run as well as external services
and APIs.
But unlike Scheduler,
Workflows gives you
the power to connect multiple
microservices as part
of your larger workflow.
When you create
your workflow, you
can use either YAML or JSON.
You specify the
order of the services
as well as how the
result of one step
can be used as either an
input to the next step
or as a condition to determine
which step to execute next.
Workflows is perfect
for chaining together
microservices, automating
infrastructure tasks
like starting or stopping a
VM, and integrating reliably
with external systems.
To execute a workflow, you
can manually trigger it
via an API call or
in the Cloud Console,
or you can set up a recurring
schedule with Cloud Scheduler.
If your focus is on engineering
data pipelines or big data
processing, you should
consider Cloud Composer.
Composer is a service
designed to orchestrate
data-driven workflows and
is built on the popular open
source Apache Airflow project.
Since it's a fully
managed service,
you don't have to worry about
managing Airflow deployments.
Composer takes care of
infrastructure management
for you so you can focus on
actually building your data
pipelines.
It also supports your
pipelines wherever they are,
whether that be on premise
or across multiple Cloud
platforms.
Like Workflows,
you create a task
for each step in your
workflow, configure the order
of the tasks, and specify
which tasks to execute next
based on some conditions.
Tasks are expressed as Python
Directed Acyclic Graph, also
known as a DAG, that
can be scheduled
to run at a time of your
choice or in response
to a particular event.
Operators allow
you to communicate
with services across multiple
cloud environments and on-prem.
In addition to many operators
in the Apache Airflow ecosystem,
there are over 150 operators
for Google Cloud alone.
For example, your
Composer workflow
might start by triggering a
data ingestion job in BigQuery,
then start a batch
processing dataflow pipeline,
and finally send a Slack
notification to teammates
that the data processing
workload has finished.
Both Composer and Workflows
are great for orchestrating
multiple services and handling
long-running workflows.
However, there are several
key differences to highlight.
Composer is designed
for orchestration
of the transformation of data as
part of ETL or data engineering
workflows.
Workflows, on the
other hand, is focus on
the orchestration of
HTTP-based services built
with Cloud Functions, Cloud
Run, and external APIs.
While Composer is
designed for orchestrating
batch workloads that can
handle a few seconds of delay
between tasks,
Workflows is designed
for more latency-sensitive
use cases.
And while Composer
tasks can be modeled
as a directed acyclic
graph, Workflows
can work for use cases where
you need loops and jumps
to already executed steps.
So there you have it-- an
introduction to orchestration
in Google Cloud and how you
can use Scheduler, Composer,
and Workflows to manage and
configure your services.
Check out the next video
on data orchestration
with Cloud Composer.